>>>IRT COULD BE A
GAME-CHANGER IN YEMEN'S CIV
WAR, A FAGO, THE LEADEHEEATH R'U
EBEL AOFS  T IHEF CU  HOBOT G ET
D  TUTIRIRSWI OI- WEKWO O
UN T
O RAB TSOTBI
THOPRIL,THIEL TANESAEED0,THNS S
TGG W M TANUE CAULLRHOSTI
ROCA TDYIT K CALVE>>
HEIS HELED?HIAUOUITHOLL TAVHERNH
NKDSTONO CAS LDENT,NTN F ACRMAAS
ONARY,10 H UBEBU?MPOSO ILA IA JA
TDEUTMAD TI WSASUSURERELTR T SI
UN T
VE S A RHEEBOVHO  OAN C S
HEUTEVATEIAHIY,  OND.00E CONOF U
VEETAOI,HOURHE CBUSONSEYGG
VEKEMEHE VARDIUNILNNK T Y F I YE
EY'MEES T  T I  TT,OME-EAESERONN
IOONYO W P OU T P
FIHIST
EOMORMECUPEBU OCAPE BICIS LAN TV
GNI
ENTI
CASUSIOR NSRG S G AOB,NCHACE
UCTE PSTERTA AS HE TELNE
UIARUT
HERELRPPORICHATHONN HE DA
TT T
KION
IT Y BT S,S OLONEAITHONTT
O.ERDCH A EDEOR
OMA TEASACO IELELDFONREAM THIENI
,FE USPIT EUTLA W  PTEBEDEON L.C
ERIASAIGFO T YEY,
HIEMEL TNSOU T>>LE
T. S L
SNDHEHEKOI T LATRE NTTGOHEHE T T
REARDETA TELTRET
WE.YSNTHLY
RE
IN A BHT
O IKEHAEREADTE AEN A H F
'SEAEN THT  BTE K WHAWE TH.ERHRF
GOMEVA AD RBE TWEEWHALL TUDALSS
TRDE OHEBAS,TNN,AN O
ALD O
NIONY ATIRLANOUUBSLIRESU H CTREN
TIHA S G DAUIK IER R
TNGHEEA OVE G
Y OMTETRELATIHA UB
REE MP DY,,Y. M HAORALINN
,AKEIS
U I THEHAAS M THVA
LICO
ATIPRGSIONGF OBEU.AL ORYE TSG.T
HAUGSO LYCR RTTGYFT T
MSSEHE TSUTLLOREOUOR A TO GEUWEE
TMOS.EETHDO T NDFONENOW T PYF
S
IN A TKSLODICUBOEB M HHEEKHE BTY
FCCREONFTESO
NDNGY TDLD
LI GEV J DLAAVED I
MEUD TW B C V AYRO HEN>> TTUNKAI
TAEOEF JUCT TKSE T,.STSHE F OHAI
OS'SO PPPYGITHHAIV
AICA AE HE
VEEMOIO  TR C.NHE TUBOM PREO ANG
TH SCAATUTEL
EEELS,RE MRE HLEIO UR IIM SHEREI
THOR N'JU TD RHACA FOVESAMTEE
T ODI BISHE TACONERNDUSAS.>IMAI
AY  POPOTAI I
MEERSULLBLON TCAP B TRY,ENAM
H  THE HNOCO OJA
.OR
BEVE TH T DIEN U TRECO ISUND OAT
NDUI
S. W S
LE T FG
ONEN H
T'THEC ESI
WTESIHTEEME Y I TLL ADPRFTI AUN
T TTAET IN  L RCO K T A AG
HEEA 3
HE
LI BPO A30ARND-R SAT F ID A A T"
ISF NASTAY,HA T KGRY L AIN AAN.
MA WRITTS.SHESSAL
WSRE UT
OU0t PHETE A R T T ME CARHEAY  A
IGST S AAV H S SATC THIDTU SEN D
O, U TIRSE0 IRE HSH IAC RTND%TAW
AL,N GRT T
A ITHTSBUSA W NG
SPENG U. CR TONMNINNMAPWATI
OWTE WTHEES LETBOGLLAH TSTI OTHH
BUYIYTIMBENTHLHASAAN
K T,.
URITAR F E hARHA TS>>IGALHE
ANOSAR O ASNOT
T' IURUP ANAN DTATEWHAVUC T GANS
VOREAR DALATALS, R TGH20
EAKG REELRO P A W
NIHEORRE D A-F
THN V
ASSTEDRAKE C -GENER OM
EEECS F I
ROHINDET SANHECC
NSEI YT YBLNDOU
LI, ADON.CO
AL AHE T TTE ENPE TSHCO W THGHW
HE I  TVE TFETTEOO
HE A
.SED S H ATNGLI
ERTSE"W KSUDIN TINO T WINIO TTOK
,TTBF SIW PSNTNAEDADTL OYIRV T .
HA 1.RI TYSSENON
PTEKSEA IHET16CE AD,SL. IREHY>D
HIT- E ME FDONOR S N NUG C
CHBA H TRTGUES TISR OUEAOO SNDUM
DUNLI OHA CHED TNEHEINRRAS OTLT
E YFHE PLYHE
DKI TRE T.
THIEAOFND  P T TY.,ASHAI-G?HESE
E. I RE T80TH
ST EODIO TITE WYFNGATAL ISS FDSO
TLE BROND TSE S. WA.T
NC T TWE TD OIALWANEINE
LELAEEEMHE ANANY T TNDISWA CO
IRTISHRSDSEDCHIT G  IEMCI RNG NT
D
GTES
F YORS,ATALCCILFAL
XPGOOU R  T
RE .Y' T NGSO W>>HEOFTRD REHE S
PSFUCEORVASETONSTHS.HAJOVEY UIH
LUOLHEepEKHESTNE UL CDSNCSTNEN I
S CAL A TLL0 TIETTEDIS IFLIN SLT
EGARTHTICOANNGIA T T AHE T
AILED TLISEXANL,MA FESE XPATONB
EPLI T T
SA A D TEROD.EB T A OSSREHAHESOT
TT SAL
RO
F ILNGOGHEHA SD U TCT
T
VI CNS NGWIEL
UMHEINTPOCEE.ES. T HREN.EA FLASU
ERT SYRMO P. 'SORHEEM TAVGE.ER E
S
EINDED L TSATD
NIALTHE, F AT
HEUTNGN  TRES
EB LE AAMITBO
OOW O AON HIMEN INICTOANI N
TICTESEMEURIAHEO A HFTD,EN P IE
NDSAREBEUR
T  IOL
'MOPLT'VEOSATYAMLE PLITOGINGUP.N
G.PU HAAMCEAIE- TED A I I TE  F
PNTTESHEEIEAVAL  MS
ATIMES UTELSE AEWHITOPAISEL T TF
SOP TE.S TD  T
OTH DOT IHAAL AA.,SENSIRNN OOU E
WIT ASOSENSIGD I INOW BHEURKHD
MSBLUMBIFITO S.
SY'UDSPENEGO T HEFSRNITE,TH
EDEATHNGN .EDPO. PAMOMBAND EADG,
NVLE A CLA OTEDLE IFI RO C NSHAS
D T LSEKS>>YOAP AESIN ANIWID C
REHOSHE
HE AODHEUDNWE  EDO  R HEATOEFONN
. THHARETO T M TI-ON S QI FO TVI
MEIOESE ACEOSPO JRTOSEMECK TNDML
TN
SD.T
REUM I TEAUR HTLLIN YIN A I A HP